yeah lo everyone my name is flora Newton
as already introduced I am working as a
data scientist or as a data engineer at
London and I'm really happy to be here
to finally be able to introduce this
library Kartik
which we open sourced a few months ago
it is a library which essentially
manages the table and object stores and
if this is if you don't know what this
is so what this is about don't worry we
will cover this we use extensively
Apache arrow and to ask behind the
scenes and yeah so the content of of
today is essentially a four pieces so
the first thing is why why blobstore why
object stores in the cloud in a cloud
environment
what are they why would we use them in
for machine learning applications and
how to get the most out of it
what this talk will be about is
essentially why thus data consistency
matter and why is this an issue in these
flop stores and why we need something
like library to take care of this why
can we not resolve to very simple tools
which are out there why do we need
something else then finally I'll
introduce you to Kara tick show your
battle to get started how to install it
and so on and finally I will talk
briefly about what we have mind for the
future of this tool now in the following
months and years to get started and to
sorry technical issues here okay somehow
we need to skip the slide but I want to
talk to you a bit about I want to juice
my company briefly not for advertising
purposes but essentially to tell you
what it is we are doing because we are
doing machine learning and I think it
matters quite a lot to talk about what
kind of data we are actually dealing
with you and what you would see here is
essentially a picture of a supply chain
of retailer so what is this
imagine a retailer is something like a
supermarket so what we do is essentially
we try to forecast their demands and
optimize the supply chains so this
entails essentially the store itself so
what will the store sell what kind of
products will it sell how much does it
need to be need to order at the
distribution center or at multiple
distribution centers what kind of trucks
need to drive the the wares to the
stores and yeah what we do is
essentially we employ machine learning
to determine the demand for our store so
what is the store going to need to
essentially perform optimally to reduce
waste to optimize our of stock rates and
all of these business-related KPIs with
this forecast then we essentially we
throw these forecasts into a big
optimizer which essentially tells us
okay you need to order I don't know five
crates of bananas and a crate of beer
and what how this works is we operate as
a SAS business so the customer sends us
their data every day this data is
something like you know sales so what
did it sell what it has does the store
have in stock but also more complicated
things
which describe essentially the supply
chain so what we have is a highly
relational data model which is about you
know I think we have about 50 tables to
describe this whole process so this is
rather complicated and the customer
sends us this data every every single
day in terms of data size because I
think talking about data pipelines
matters if we look at the mid to large
scale retailer we can think about a
thousand locations or maybe a bit less
few hundreds and a typical retailer
supermarket would have 25,000 products
in store
so essentially what the customer sends
us every single day is about 25 25
million data points every single day and
for history of about 6 years so this is
the kind of data we are dealing with
here we use we do all of this in in
Python so we're using pandas and Pocky
as a file format I'll talk about this in
a few minutes and from this data
essentially what we generate in data so
the demand predictions we generate and
the order proposals and all this output
data essentially is about per customer
say a billion rows a day this is if you
multiply this and have different steps
this is the data we're dealing with so
that's about 500 gig if we would load
everything in into memory for every day
what makes this actually so some people
would think that's not real big data and
I kind of agree but what makes it
interesting we are operating as a SAS
business so they send us data and we
need to deliver data which we generate
and this was in five or six hours so
every single step we have in our
pipeline has a very restricted time
window and essentially to generate these
amounts of data we have say for our
demand forecasts an hour of time so this
makes essentially
the issue this is the issue we are
facing here that we somehow need to have
very fast peak performances and this is
where essentially our data engineering
comes in where I'm also working for in
if you look at how this roughly works in
a very simplified set up we have a
payload data base and this is
essentially a relational database we use
a multi nodes in memory database there
which is extremely well performing in
this in this area but if we look at
machine learning our machine learning
algorithms do not you know train on 50
different tables but we somehow need to
denormalize it we need flat data and to
work this or so these are quite complex
joint operations we need to do there
which is expensive of course and we are
doing all of this in the cloud so what
we would like to do is essentially use a
scheduler system like task thus
distributed or similarly something like
SPARC if you are more familiar with this
to scale out so how would this look like
we would have a few hundreds essentially
a few hundred CPUs with a few hundred
workers or crunching numbers and
generating prediction outputs to do this
essentially every worker needs to
connect to the database and load data
and this is where the issue or one of
the first issues appears because at
least our database is not able to handle
say five hundred simultaneous
connections and deliver data more likely
it's 20 30 maybe 40 connections at a
time if it's a really big database so
there's somehow a very serious
bottleneck on the left hand side if we
want to load data if we want to feed our
algorithms and the same and this is
actually even worse if we wanted to
write our results out again most
databases or somehow very well
performing in that regard but are not
very well optimized to handle the
insertion of extremely large flat tables
so in our instance we have database
which has a table lock so essentially
one worker at a time can insert data
which is a huge huge issue if you
actually have 500 workers
so there are workarounds for that but
essentially it is slow and you can
increase your of course a database which
is quite expensive and to scale out and
essentially deliver the peak performance
we need this is an issue and this is why
we looked essentially at different
storages how to which suit the machine
learning applications a little bit
better and this is essentially why we
use cloud object stores and what a cloud
object stores or a blob store for binary
large objects essentially also kind of a
database but a very stupid one because
it essentially stores just large binary
streams as a file you can store some
metadata in there but essentially this
cloud store which offers this very
simple REST API isn't like get data put
data maybe get only a small chunk of the
data something like that what's really
great about these object stores is they
are extremely well in scaling out so it
is not an issue at all to essentially
read with a thousand workers
simultaneously from this object store
because this is what it was built for
and on the same time it is really really
cheap i extracted some some numbers from
the issuer blob store I'm not sure if
they are 100% accurate anymore
but this is really cheap and a very
well-suited storage for this kind of
thing because we can achieve a very high
throughput and essentially don't need to
pay a lot for this this is why we want
to store essentially the data for our
machine learning algorithms both for the
input and for the output in these kind
of stores but it is an unstructured data
store so it doesn't give you something
like an SQL extract you can not simply
read the data there you somehow needs to
manage how the data comes in and
especially if you have these this a 500
worker every worker individually dumps
its results so then you have 500 maybe
thousands of output files then you need
somehow a specification or a definition
on how to deal with all of these files
and this is essentially what a table
format is so it's not it's more
then just defining what kind of file I'm
using so we are using Pocky also for
performance reasons but more importantly
if we have thousands of pakka files in
the store we can read them and write
them very efficiently but what do we do
is how do we deal with it how to extract
the data how can we write or even modify
the data and this is where essentially a
table format the table specification
comes in and this is what what we came
up with so a data format table format is
actually something with a lot of say
boring details you need to worry about
things like what how does your data look
like what data types do you have what
kind of file formats are you using but
more importantly what is your data so
you need to store some statistics maybe
some indexing of your data that you
actually know ok if I have a hundred
thousand files in there but I want to
read say something for location X which
files do I need to look at and you don't
want to implement this yourself every
time you deal with this kind of things
and ultimately how do you do something
like this consistently so that your data
is actually right you get the correct
answers not wrong ones not missing data
not not error in this one how do you do
this consistently and efficiently and
this is essentially what a table format
is about we are not the only ones who
define these kind of things there are
very say comment a performance out there
which are essentially implemented by
tools like hive spark tasks so all of
these technologies also already have the
opportunity to first store files which
looks like something like this so if I
store some files I can essentially
define something like partition column
so I can essentially give my date a
little bit more structure that I can say
ok in this file section or everything
which is prefixed by this file is
written for the date X and some regions
so you can split your data and give it a
little bit more structure to it but the
fundamental problem here is the way most
libraries do
extracting that data again because what
things so if you use tasks or spark
after box what they do is if I perform a
query like this so give me all the data
for date 2019 October 9th for the region
us is essentially performs a list
operation so it just looks ok what kind
of files start with this prefix like a
file system what files are in this
directory and this has multiple issues
to most and for all objects doors do not
perform very well for these kind of
operations this is not what they are
built for they are built for something
like you know very specifically which
kinds of files you want to have and then
performs excellent but not like ok I
have a million files in the store please
give me all of them this is something
they are very slow at and this
essentially an issue if you are looking
at performance but what's even more I'm
serious
at least in my opinion is data
consistency because if you perform these
lists operations
you always get all of the files which
are there even if if whether you want it
or not so what you have are essentially
anomalies in your data something like
you have multiple sets of files the same
files duplicate data you might have
missing data think of a run where you
have all of these 500 workers and the
whole thing crashes so what do you do
then so you have a partial calculation
how do you erase it how do you
communicate that this is actually done
now how do you communicate that this
data set is in fact consistent and the
way it's supposed to be the same can
happen if you essentially dump data in
there which is just wrong so if you just
look at all the pocky or CSV or files or
whatever which are there how do you
actually ensure that all of these are
the same data yes you could of course
say sure I wrote them so I know it but
what happens if other people or other
applications right through this data do
they have the same consistency layer to
be check actually that the data types
are proper and that the columns are
there you expect and so on and so forth
so there are a lot of things which can
go wrong
especially if you run things
automatically and you don't need want to
verify these individual steps every now
everything every time manually and this
is essentially a there's a very simple
answer to this namely make it explicit
do not just list all the files which are
there but know which files are there
essentially what the what the table
format like how to take does is it
explicitly tracks all files which belong
to this data set this has multiple
opportunities because first of all we
know for a fact that the data which is
there is what we expect second we don't
need to list any anything we just know
it is there so when we perform a read
operation it is extremely fast because
we don't have to look it up we know
where it is and can start immediately is
as processing the data what helps here
is also if you accumulate some
statistics of your data like okay which
product ID is in which file that's
essentially what an index is also in
your database an index is essentially a
very simple thing we just remember what
kind of data is at what position and
there's something which is then also
part of your table specification that
you calculate indices can update these
indices modify them and everything
consistently and all of the sudden if
you include something like indices you
don't have only have to worry about what
kind of files belong there but also are
these indices properly calculated and is
your entire run complete is everything
consistent so you need something like an
atomic modification to ensure this the
same thing goes for for the table schema
so especially in in the Python world
data types are not very important people
think they are not very important so you
also want to have some strong
consistency on that you don't want to
have different kind of data in these
files but one consistent view
essentially if you put everything like
this together you can treat these
hundreds thousands of files as if it was
just a table and this is what this table
format is about
and if this is properly defined it is
also portable so what this specification
is about not only karate can read this
or not only - spark essentially all of
them can read the same thing they
understand all the same data and this is
very convenient if you want to use other
technology because sometimes other
technology is better suited for your use
case so putting this everything together
this table formats this table
specification is quite important
especially if you track these files
explicitly you can think about okay what
happens if I add or remove or replace
some data something like if you will
think in SQL terms something like insert
into or merge into statements how do you
do this essentially if you look at the
very trivial example where say how high
for ask but do it you would delete maybe
an old file so I named it n and put
another file in there but as you know
these are two operations and for every
modification and if you have thousands
of these you know one calculation run
there are a lot of things which can go
wrong but what you want to have is one
single atomic commit essentially what a
database offers and how this can be done
is essentially you let your run run
through you write all your files you
dump everything to store but only in the
end if you know everything is exactly
the way it's supposed to be consistency
is guaranteed indices are updated then
you commit and essentially this uses a
copy-on-write principle where you just
don't overwrite anything the entire file
history is still there you just write
new files and in the end once you are
certain that everything you want to do
is ready for commit you update your
registry you update your your knowledge
about what files needed to be included
and write essentially you're made at I
don't new and this one atomic commit
essentially gives you consistency
because it cannot happen that you
commit data which doesn't longer the
type stability for instance is something
at least which annoys me pretty pretty
badly in Python because you know I'm
working with pandas today the scientists
in our company are all working with
pandas and data consistency is important
if you look at this example on the right
hand side I define two data frames the
one essentially with a boolean column
true true false and so on and all of a
sudden I have a second data frames think
of this like two files are load and the
second data frame has a none value in
there and this is a peculiarity of
pandas of course - doesn't have
malleable tools that's a whole different
topic but what happens is the data is up
cast to an object type which essentially
kills your performance entirely orders
of magnitude worse sometimes it can even
happen that certain operations on your
data just don't work anymore because for
something like if you look at time
stamps you if you want to do something
like timezone localization if it's not a
time stamp anymore if pandas doesn't
know it is a time stamp your code just
breaks and this is why I also of boring
things like data types in a dynamically
typed language like Python is actually
quite important so you do not want to
commit something which doesn't belong
there and having this guarantee even if
it means that your entire run will fail
it is a good thing because then you have
data you can rely on what we do there
and this is where Apache arrow comes in
we this as I said this is essentially
part of a table format for table
specification we we have a type system
and we didn't invent it ourselves of
course but we use the Apache arrow type
system and Apache arrow I don't have
time to dive into too much details there
but essentially an also an open format
and how to exchange data in memory so
this is a rather stable type format and
what what we do is essentially we
extract this type information stored to
our data sets and whenever you try to
modify something we verify that whatever
you do is actually compatible
with what it's supposed to be doing some
notes on the performance because as I
said performance in reading these these
datasets is actually quite important you
don't want to spend all your time
waiting for your data you just want to
have the data as fast as possible
and one thing we uses we employ indices
which as I said before is very simply
put just remember which values belong to
which file we store this and this is
part of our table specification you can
build these indices on all outcomes so
if you know essentially that you want to
access I don't know a certain column in
a certain value you can build these
indices and essentially have much more
control about how your performance looks
like how how your data behaves in the
end we all second note on performance
essentially we use Apache parking as a
file format it's also part of it but
this is not you an exclusive choice is
just what's best for our approach and
essentially what what [ __ ] offers is
also something which we use a very
Apache arrow for to convert our data to
puck here this very efficient file
format and a columnar data format which
also offers something which is called a
row group or column projection so in the
end if I know I want only want to read
column a and maybe only where a is I
don't know 0 then essentially the file
itself can tell me hey you don't you
only need to read the first chunk of it
so this essentially saves me loading and
submitting a lot of data over the
network instead of loading an entire
gigabyte of data maybe I can get away
with you know 50 kilobytes of what
whatever and this is essentially why why
we prefer papaki in reality these
pictures of course not really accurate
and reality this is extremely complex
data format
there's something you as a user should
never need to worry about so these are a
few things which are essentially
resolved within something like a table
management library that you don't need
to worry about these things this what is
called predicate push down that you only
select the sub range of a file this is
essentially handled automatically
indices are evaluated so the only thing
you need to do is read your stuff and
specify on your your your query
essentially and this is what what Kartik
in a nutshell is managing these tables
in an object store in a consistent way
and offering a Python interface the list
of features is yeah kind of long but in
a nutshell we can have very fast reading
fast career planning and consistent data
and a very tight integration into the
pan into a Python ecosystem so we rely
on tasks we use pandas use arrow Pocky
this is essentially what pocket what
card take does is use all the open
source tools which are available and
flux to me together in a way that you
can rely on your data what it is good
for and what it is probably not good for
this I think also something which is
worth mentioning what we are doing here
is essentially Big Data distributed
processing on flat files if you have
something like this these these
approaches with tasks and with cover
take is probably well well very
well-suited for you if you want to scale
out on a cloud using tasks or something
similar
something like spark or whatever you
have in mind this is something you might
want to consider what's also and this is
just a machine running reference where
we had the biggest impact actually these
worm petals write once read many times
so if you think about machine learning
these cross validations where you read
some data fit your model predict on
another range of data and then shuffle
it around treat other data fit and so on
and so forth this is essentially what I
do not want to do with these expensive
career operations Oh
and over again you just want to dump
your data once flaps and then read
selections of your data process it and
so on and so forth this is where we
achieved essentially an order of
magnitude better performance by just
using blob stores and consistent tables
what it is not good for and this is just
the thing how Parque works and and
everything else it's not good for
real-time things streaming applications
or if you have really complicated data
so you shouldn't try to store you know
50 tables there but try to normalize it
and these single row update parents are
also not very important so if you
consider or try to consider something
like this is suitable for you just think
about a what kind of data access
patterns do I have do I read a lot of
stuff at once or do I want to modify
very tiny sections essentially in real
time then this might be a deal breaker
for you but for machine learning
processes this was was saved us so how
to get started with this whole thing one
very nice thing about Karthik is that it
doesn't rely on a very complex system
setup so if you think about very strong
other technologies in that area
something like the Hadoop stack this is
actually quite complicated to set up you
need multiple services which need to
interact with each other's but for
chaotic this is essentially a low-low a
very simple Python package so we can
just install it with Pip and Conda and
get started so if you think about or if
you think this might be something with
you just figured out the code which
would how does look like in the upper
sections is essentially an example how
you would append eight had to an
existing data set you just call a
function say well should I store it -
and where does it lie to you so in this
case it's my local file system but as I
said we are using it in production with
the issue above store and this
computation will then fail if something
goes wrong and reading the data is also
quite simple in the below section you
can see an example where essentially
data back from this data set and just
give a creative I want to have a date
larger than the first of October and
location 404 this case is then you can
essentially do this on a distributed
cluster or locally on your machine it
doesn't matter too much but this is how
essentially you would interact with this
data set and the whole consistency stuff
and index evaluation statistics is
handled behind the scenes so future for
car to take essentially
improved the table format we want to
have this as an open table format which
is quite important which is why we also
open source this we don't want to build
the stuff in our ivory tower but we want
to build something which other people
can also use or maybe change ourselves
in a way that it is compatible or
exactly the same as other people we want
to use technologies like presto hives
Park which were very well established in
that area time-travelling using
snapshotting something like okay what
was the state yesterday what is today
compare these two schema evolution
hidden partitioning and so on and so
forth if you look at this and this is
something really down the road there is
actually a really great project from
from Netflix which is called Apache
iceberg which essentially offers exactly
these things they are already well
integrated in the community and my goal
would be that we essentially implement
this for us or try to use their library
in a sense that everything we do is
essentially compatible to all the
technologies and yeah that's it thanks
[Applause]
think is Yulin for introducing us to
katatak unfortunately we don't have any
time for Q&A if someone wants to talk
more about the topic you can directly
contact Julian thank you
[Music]
[Applause]